it was also in 2014 that i started to
work out
a little inspiration for my son i i used
to i used to
i used to be fairly hefty i used to be
240 245.
so i started working out in the spring
of 2014 um
switched from coke to diet coke i wasn't
been anything intensive i wasn't running
i was lifting weights three days a week
but i started losing 35 pounds in less
than six weeks
then it was 40 then it was 45
and i'm like wow this this this working
out and switching to diet coke really
works well
then i started to have some some
symptoms of tingling in my fingers
tingling in my toes
pain in my neck intestinal issues and
the weight just kept melting off and
there was no
increased stress yet in the marriage so
i can't attribute it to anxiety from
stress on the home front
but i would ultimately discover that
that's when
i believe um she was putting arsenic
in my protein powder it would take me a
couple years to figure that out but
the symptoms and the weight loss with
some blood work got so bad that
i had elevated white blood cell counts
i had liver enzymes that were
significantly off i had another enzyme
called
creatinine phosphokinase that is you
know normally elevated with a heart
attack
a stroke or a brain injury or crushing
muscle injury
that was significantly elevated and they
took him a few years to figure out
actually
what was happening but i was evaluated
for on early onset of
als uh parkinson's uh leukemia
and so i you know i'm going through all
sorts of health issues and
uh and uh it was at that same time that
uh
her mother got involved in the game what
was she trying to do with the
i mean she was trying to kill you uh
yeah i believe she was trying to kill me
and we never i could never i don't even
people say why is she not in jail well i
by the time i discovered this i'd been
bounced out of the house and we had been
separated for a year
and so i no longer had access to the
protein powder but
she would religiously pull that protein
powder out of the cupboard when i was
still in the home
and accuse me of putting something in
there she'd pull it out she'd want to
read the label to me again i'm like it's
100 whey protein
i'm not going through this again it's
like you're putting something in your
protein powder
of what putting something in it to lose
the weight and gain the muscle
you know beyond like the protein drugs
or whatever because that's that's when
the accusations of drugs started to
begin because i was getting thin and
that only fueled her
infidelity piece and also with her
mother because it's like you're working
out you've lost 45 pounds now
we got a we got a couple of comments
here from some of our regular viewers
like we got a guy here saying you know
her
smv was lowering meaning her sexual
marketplace value was lower than yours
yeah she was thinking yours was higher
and you were going to move on
like did she fall apart during the
marriage did she put on weight did her
uh no no she didn't uh
actually and you know certainly what i
would later discover that you know she
was not only
abusing adderall and adderall xr but
also riddle in la which is a long-acting
form of another amphetamine so she
her her weight was not never an issue
but she she had a lot of and i think
your listeners comment is
pretty accurate she had a lot of health
issues i mean and those dated back to
2001 so in addition to
borderline personality disorder and
narcissistic never officially diagnosed
by anybody
for narcissism or borderline no but no
because anybody that she went to she was
able to fool them
um so nobody ever believed it was her
they always believed that it was me that
she was in the controlling and an
abusive marriage and
he's got anger issues and of course oh
by the way i was the one that spent nine
days in a psychiatric facility i was the
one that was
misdiagnosed with bipolar ii um and that
that occurred
in the fall of 2014 after staying on an
island
keeping it all to myself and enduring
six months of
harassment from her mother and from her
and accusations of infidelity and drug
addiction and
lack of trust in our marriage and like i
said
my video clip to you they just hollowed
me out i mean
no no that's exhausting i completely
understand the
the um uh was she a stay-at-home mom
does she work like
she was she was there yeah of course
as you know how that plays out well
maybe you don't i don't know what you
said
guys that that were kind of lined up
over the years or was it just one guy
that she was cheating
on with you we never figured it out you
never got to the bottom of it
no because she as we move forward to our
alimony trial and we had phones imaged
and computers imaged and my daughter's
ipad my daughter's phone image and all
my stuff image she restored her phone to
factory settings
so she wiped wiped her phone and she
also wiped all the computers that she
had in her possession so
the only thing that she turned over to
me was uh 14 emails
14 1-4 textbook gaslighting is what's
that
abs absolutely i'm laughing about that
now because
i also went through a domestic violence
trial after i was out of the house she
filed domestic violence charges against
me and
we resided in north carolina at the time
and north carolina is a non-pleading
state so you can say whatever you want
and you'll get your day in court well
she she she claimed that she was afraid
of me and my daughter was afraid of me
and i was going to kill her
and so we ended up in a domestic
violence court
and my smile was because my my domestic
violence attorney
covered the mic when she was on the
stand and leaned over to me and he said
she's uh
she's gaslighting you and i said i said
what does that mean
he said look it up and sure enough i got
very well educated about gaslighting
so um she was accusing you of
of drugs and cheating and you got locked
up so
did you did you commit yourself or or
did she
like somehow influence this process to
get you locked up like
the psychiatric ward thing i'm confused
about that can you kind of break that
down
yeah absolutely i was confused about it
too i bet
what am i doing here yeah well how did i
end up here um
but so again spring of 2014 she starts
in with these accusations the mom her
mother gets in on the game
we're on a beach trip in june of 2014
with her little family and my our two
kids
and uh i was on that lovely beach trip
uh that her mother
threatened to kill me so just i came up
to the kitchen just to get a soda
and her mother and her had gone
somewhere and they're standing at the
end of the counter i'll never forget it
and uh her mother just looks me dead in
the eye from the end of the counter and
says
you put your hands on my daughter i'll
kill you
perhaps you're addicted to porn perhaps
you're addicted to drugs there's
something going on
something maybe that happened in your
childhood you need to figure it out you
need to
you need to dig deep into yourself so it
was the apple doesn't fall far from the
tree in that family yeah
right right so it was what it was
whatever she was feeding her mother
whatever she was telling her mother
and again a woman that i unconditionally
loved for 23 years
welcomed her into my home took her on
vacations but
she turned on me like a cobra and
offered no explanation
when i asked her i did ask her once i
got over the shock i said what
what have i ever done to your daughter
that would lead you to think i was going
to kill her
and i was going to hurt her and she had
to think about it she says well
she told me that one time when you got
angry at her you shook the dishwasher
rack and you broke it
i said i didn't break it i did shake it
but of course this is at the height
of what she's just badgering me you know
every other day with some type of crazy
paranoid delusional accusation so that
occurred in june
in september um of that year of 2014
again i spent the summer just kind of
staying on an island doing my own thing
feeling empty feeling like a piece of
dirt
and um you know i was that was at that
point that all i had all the weight loss
going on i had all sorts of medical
issues that i couldn't figure out what
was happening with me
and she friday night september 13th she
called the cops on me
september 14th i went down to charlotte
north carolina to
see my son because my daughter had
already been alienated from me i wanted
him to know
what was going on i want him to hear
directly from me
um and i didn't want to lose him too so
when i got back from there um
she had decided at that point that yeah
i think we i think it's time i think
it's
i think it's time for us to separate and
um
it was the thought of me losing my
family
uh when i went to see the family
practitioner that following monday
she was kind enough to go with me so the
thought of me losing my family
and all the instability and all the
things that had happened that
he looked at me and said well if you
lose your family what are you gonna do
and i said i don't know what i'm gonna
do i don't know what i will do without
my family
and he interpreted that that simple
little statement in less than two
minutes he says to me
i think you're bipolar and if you don't
go to such and such a hospital i'll have
you involuntarily committed
so the same guy a few years later would
backtrack i didn't see him anymore but
he would backtrack and call it you know
call it anxiety
how long uh how long do they keep you
there for well i went to one
facility uh went to the place that he
said i needed to go to a dedicated
psychiatric facility
and i show up with my little piece of
paper again i'm a broken man i'm just i
don't know how i was walking
show up at the window with my little
piece of paper that says i think i might
hurt myself
and the nice gentleman behind the window
says ah it's an eight to ten hour wait
grab a seat so i'm like i'm not staying
here
so being in the pharmaceutical medical
industry i knew the hospitals in the
area i knew a place that had a
psychiatric facility it was an acute
care hospital
went there and handed them my little
piece of paper and
sure enough i stayed there for for three
days
and then i got a police escort to the
place i tried to avoid they
sent me there three days later for
another six-day stay
and uh my civil rights were violated um
because after i got out i looked at what
the north carolina law was
and they should have reevaluated me
within 24 hours
as to whether or not this involuntary
commitment is
necessary and i didn't see another
psychiatric health care worker for 72
hours
this sounds like it went on for years
how are you able to
work like you've got a business to run
well it's interesting
um so got out of psychiatric facility
after nine days
a couple of my brothers came to town
which is i'm great that's when i finally
let people into my world let them know
what was going on
and i stayed in the marriage whether
it's right or wrong
um i don't regret it now because of the
revelation that i received six or seven
months later
but i stayed in the marriage and was
manipulated out of the house in may of
2015.
um while i was still in the home i
actually got promoted into the position
i have now
so i was able to dial in work-wise i was
able to stay
focused none of my none of the folks
that i work with
my boss none of them knew what was going
on personally they knew there was
something going on with my health
because at that point i had lost
70 pounds and i just look like death
and you know when the book came out a
lot of them that have read it said oh
now this makes sense you know i didn't
want to say anything to you at this
particular meeting but
we all thought you were dying of
something um so yeah ironically and
and you know by the grace of god i was
able to get promoted into this position
so
but i'm in california in december
2015 four or five months before i left
the house was manipulated out of the
house and
getting ready for a third interview for
this job
and she calls me a half hour beforehand
and once again says i think we need to
separate
and at this point i just got to the
point of just being laughing in her face
and i'm like you realize i have a
third and final interview a half hour
from now she says no i'm aware of that
but i just
wanted to get that off my chest and i'm
like okay you just you wanted to derail
me again
so fortunately somehow i was promoted
into this position and
haven't missed a beat you know from a
work perspective it's amazing that you
actually
accomplished that going through a train
wreck of a divorce because i know that
when i was going through it it was it
was really hard for me to get anything
done at the office
um yeah but uh yeah that's that's that's
one of the exhausting things that nobody
really talks about
you